[Music]
well I happen to be a fan of democracy I
think it has flaws but there was just no
other better system for one simple
reason and that is you can often get a
beneficent dictator a lot of people
think that Lee Kuan Yew in Singapore was
such a person he was not corrupt
he actually alleviated a lot of the
ethnic conflict but here's the problem
you can never insure that the dictator
will stay beneficent and the better
thing about democracy is that eventually
you can vote them out if you don't like
the policies if you don't like the
leaders you can vote them out so on
balance I think that democracy is the
best system what I think is wrong is
that America treats democracy like a
panacea we romanticize it we think
somehow that oh there's all the Civil
War and tribalism and sectarian warfare
there let's just have some elections
what they don't realize is that in very
divided countries ethnically divided
tribally divided democracy can sometimes
catalyze group conflict rather than
softening it a lot of people have
puzzled over how so many blue-collar and
working-class Americans could possibly
have voted for a billionaire born to
wealth born in Manhattan but it's
actually not a puzzle at all but a lot
of working-class Americans resent is the
idea that there's a rigged system that
there are these people arrogant people
controlling the levers of power from
afar somewhere in DC and on Wall Street
in Silicon Valley if you look at the
surveys Pew foundation studies you find
that most Americans including
working-class Americans actually love
capitalism they don't want socialism
they still want a system where you could
work hard you can strike it rich and
they want it to be fine to be rich
studies show that many working-class
Americans actually resent the
professional elites war the very
polished well-educated snobby professors
and journalists and pundits
speaking on TV and that they don't
actually dislike the Kardashian so much
or the billionaires that are jet-setting
around
that's why shows like The Apprentice are
so popular the Occupy movement in many
important things highlighting the
urgency of inequality in this country
but one problem with the Occupy movement
is that it was a movement that purported
to want to help the poor that didn't
actually include any members of the poor
it was overwhelmingly an extremely
privileged movement not necessarily
wealthy but highly educated and largely
from cosmopolitan urban areas and if you
look at the interviews of people from
other parts of the country working class
people blue-collar people it's not just
that they didn't participate in these
activist anti quality movements they
actually were very suspicious of them
and even a little scornful the
interviews have people saying don't
these people have jobs don't they have
to work I'm working three jobs just to
put food on the table how can they be
marching and protesting all the time now
that's a little unfair because a lot of
these activist movements have done
tremendous good but it is also true that
it is a privilege to have the time to
take off work and to do these things so
there's a real schism in group
identities a lot of America's elites
while they were campaigning for Bernie
or Hillary didn't really connect with so
many of the lower-income Americans
because in part they had a snobby view
towards them but the point is that a lot
of America's political elites the
establishment elites just really didn't
bother to get to understand the people
that supposedly they were trying to help
it's amazing to contrast the Occupy
movement with the prosperity gospel the
irony is just glaring so occupy was a
movement championing supposedly the
underclasses
but largely driven by elites the
prosperity gospel is a hugely popular
movement in America one of the most
powerful religious movements in the
United States that is very largely
populated by
advantaged Americans including our most
disadvantaged minorities
african-americans and Hispanic Americans
are flocking to the prosperity gospel
what is their creed that God blesses the
wealthy that being rich is divine and
that if you pray for wealth hard enough
God will give it to you and this
contrast just shows the the tribal chasm
between America's haves and have-nots
you have people purporting to want to
help the other side and yet actually
scorning the very movements that those
people actually belong to we have a
strange relationship with celebrity
culture in America and in some ways you
could see the victory of Donald Trump as
Donald Trump tapping into this obsession
with celebrities it's almost like he's
created a kind of billionaire populism
where he's tapping into this desire for
a lot of working-class people to rise in
a system where they can no longer rise
where there's so much inequality that
they can't just make it with hard work
and they romanticize that they think you
know what if I go on American Idol or
the voice or shark tank maybe I can hit
it big and they actually glorify all the
Desperate Housewives or the Kardashians
or the celebrity musicians and actresses
these are beloved figures they're not
hated at all it's like the royal family
in England the desire for the American
Dream is so powerful that people will
cling to it even when they have no
chance even when the American Dream
turns their backs on people mocks them a
lot of Americans would sooner turn on
immigrants Outsiders even reason itself
then turn on the American dream a lot of
people think why is this happening now
you know what what's going on with our
society well it's always been there a
lot of these issues have always been
there there's always been these male
bosses that have done these terrible
things so it's not like it's all
happening now it's just that finally
certain groups voices are allowed to be
heard it's the same with a lot of
diversity issues you know people will
say why now are there so many
minorities complaining on campuses or in
this organization it used to be so
smooth things used to work so well
well that's because so many voices used
to be suppressed so in a way I think
it's healthy what's often experienced as
turbulence and chaos oh my gosh
everything's going haywire is actually a
healthy rising of certain voices that
historically have not been allowed to
speak and there are lots of different
groups it's you know along all kinds of
different lines gender race ethnicity I
mean it's it's everything
[Music]